Hello world,
it's Suraj and are you ready to learn
computer science in five months?
Crazy, right. I know. Welcome to my world.
Traditional universities tend to offer
a CS major that gives students a path to
go from no programming experience to
having a broad understanding of the many
disciplines at the field of
computer science encompasses.
In this video I'm going to give you my
condensed version of a computer science
major one that will take
you five months to Spanish.
This is the kind of study plan I create
for myself if I wanted to not only learn
how to code but to have a
basic understanding of the
most important areas of
computer science.
All the resources I'm going to list here
are free and available on the Internet
and if you want to stay up to
date with my educational content,
don't forget to hit the
subscribe button before we start.
Remember you should speed up the time it
takes to complete the courses I list by
speeding up videos,
dedicating two to three hours a day to
this doing only one project per course at
the end of the week, and handwriting
notes as you go for memory retention.
Oh,
and remember to follow some
notable computer scientists
while you learn that all
list here so you can stay
up to date in this field.
We're going to start our journey by
learning the python programming language.
Python is an interpreted object oriented,
high level programming language
with dynamics semantics, WTF,
right?
I know lots of jargon to take in.
Let's start with a learning resource
that requires no knowledge of CS jargon.
There's a great free book online called
automate the boring stuff with python.
It's a practical guide to
programming for our total beginners.
It shows you how to do some basic
tasks like sending reminder emails,
moving files and formatting
data using the python language.
Spend the first week reading this book.
It's 18 chapters long,
so if you split it up into
three or four chapters a day,
you will finish it by the end of the week.
This book has a bunch of exercises in
it that you can execute from terminal on
whatever kind of operating
system your using.
If you need help installing
python on your machine,
definitely check out python.org
for details on how to do
that in the second week
of learning python. I'd recommend taking
the Code Academy Course on Python.
It's got this really fun interactive
console in your web browser so you can get
instant feedback on your code and
whether it compiles correctly.
It's gotten really popular with beginners
over the years and they've got a bunch
of other cool courses you can check
out later, two weeks in total.
It should be a good amount of time to
get the basics of python down. Yes,
the applications you'll be building
in these first two weeks aren't world
changing, but understanding the
syntax of the language, the keywords,
how often they're used,
why they're used are crucial to
help you get to the next step.
Building and understanding
data structures.
I remember when I was a computer
science freshmen at Columbia,
one of the mantras that everyone would
tell me was that data structures and
algorithms are the most important subjects
you'll ever take for your major and
at the time it seemed ludicrous.
How could that be more important than
say learning something much more exciting
like robotics or computer vision?
Well, it turns out they were right.
Being able to build cool things for the
endless applications of computer science
requires you to understand how to
properly store data and manipulate it to
accomplish your task.
Ed X has a great course on data structures
talk by Uc San Diego that will show
you how all the various data structures
from binary trees to link lists work
with implementations in python. After
that you want to move into algorithms.
Perhaps the best course for this that
uses python as its base language is the
intro to algorithms course by Mit.
You can find all the lecturers associated
notes and problem sets in one place on
their website.
You'll notice when it comes to data
structures and algorithms that once you
start building and
understanding a couple of them,
everything starts to make sense.
You start to understand the trade off
you'll have to make when it comes to
sorting data and storing it properly
and when you start thinking of
applications,
you'll be able to tell what types of data
structures and algorithms you'll need
to accomplish the task on to the next one.
Whether you're building a web APP or a
mobile app or even just working with data
in general. It's important to
understand how databases work.
Sequel is the most popular
standard language for
databases and Coursera has this
course called databases with python that
will help you understand that easily.
You can go ahead and skip the first
week of this course since you've already
covered the learning python bit and had
straight into the rest of it for the
next week.
We'll take a short break from python
to focus on networking before you start
building apps that use the
internet. You've got to
understand how this internet,
this nervous system for humanity that
actually allows us to communicate
instantly and globally works.
Coursera has got a course
that was created by Google,
cleverly called the bits and
bites of computer networking.
You'll learn how the internet protocol
suite works and finally understand what
happens under the hood when you type a
website into the URL bar and hit enter.
After you've done this,
you're ready to dive into the world
of web and mobile programming.
I'm a big fan of the computer science
professor David Milan at Harvard.
He's got a really charming enthusiasm
about him that keeps you engaged.
The best course for this is Harvard's
cs 50 web programming with python and
javascript. Yes, we've
only covered python so far,
but it's necessary to
understand javascript, the
language of the web as well.
You can find the videos in
a simple youtube playlist
and he'll show you how you
can combine some of the most important
technologies of web programming together
to create elegant web apps that
anybody can access from a web browser.
Spend the next week building a single
web app that really excites you,
but it's also doable in a single week.
Don't get too ambitious.
Elsie will be able to finish
it and you'll get discouraged.
There are some great examples on get hub
that can serve as inspiration and it'll
give you practice using stack overflow.
One of the most important
tools for programmers for
quick and easy explanations
for how and why to use certain
programming techniques.
When it comes to mobile development,
you've got two options.
Ios and android spend the first week
building an Ios APP and the second week
building an android APP.
That way you can see the difference
between both and realize which type of
programming environment you prefer and
build the same app in both environments
to really see where the differences
are built. Something really simple.
It'll be a challenge to even get a simple
app set up because you first got to
install the dependencies and learn how
their respective ids work like x code and
android studio. Now that we've got
the fundamental stuff out of the way,
let's move on to the funner stuff.
Data Science is the art of
making discoveries from data.
Usually this is done using statistical
analysis and machine learning methods.
Add X has a course called python
for data science taught by UC SD.
That would be a great way to jump
into this field. It's especially long,
so spread this one out to two weeks.
It'll help put your python knowledge to
immediate use and you'll get familiar
with popular python libraries for
data science like pandas and num py.
After this, you'll have just a bit
of knowledge of machine learning,
which contains so many different
disciplines in an of itself.
It'll take you a while to
really learn all of it,
but a great way to dive into this
field is to pick applied fields of ml,
like natural language processing
and computer vision and study.
Those dedicate a single week to each.
Coursera has got a great course on
NLP and you'd Udacity has a course on
computer vision taught by Georgia Tech.
One thing to remember is that it's not
just enough to know how to program.
You need to know how to program in a team.
That's why you should dedicate the
next week to learning the software
development process.
Coursera has a course called software
development processes and methodologies
that covers all the different team based
techniques for working on code with
other people.
If you want to work at a company,
be at Google or the smallest startup,
it's essential to know this stuff
for the last week of this curriculum.
Usually get a broad overview
of the cryptocurrency
blockchain space because it's
so hot right now, not because it's
the most advanced topic to tackle,
but because it's a very current
topic and a hot one at that.
I've got a great crypto currency playlist
for you on youtube that you should
check out.
I hope my curriculum is helpful to you.
You'll find all the links
necessary down below.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to learn how to learn.
So thanks for watching.